[Music]
I remember that around midnight Cyrus
halted the Army on an open plane it
seemed he wished to hold a full review
of the combined Greek and Asiatic forces
he expected the great king ARA Xerxes to
arrive the following day and offer
battle Cyrus summoned the generals and
captains of the Greeks to arrange the
plan of battle he began the meeting with
the following words listen to me Greeks
he said I'm commanding you as my allies
but that is not because I lack troops to
fight in my battles it's because I
believe you are stronger and Superior to
most foreign soldiers but I want you to
know what type of struggle you're about
to engage in I know the nature of these
conflicts the enemy have vast numbers
and would Advance against you with great
noise but if you withstand the oncoming
numbers and uproar then to my shame you
will find that these Asiatic troops are
pitiful Fighters so maintain the courage
of brave
men clarus also asked Cyrus do you
really think that your brother will give
battle and Cyrus answered the throne
will not be one without battle because
my brother is a true son of
Darius we Greeks possessed 10,400
hotlights heavy infantry supported by
2,500 light equipped missile troops
Cyrus had 200 sced chariots and 6,000
Persian Cavalry led by arter gares and
so we continued the March for three more
days without encountering the
enemy when we'd almost reached the
halting place to make Camp a Persian Man
Came Galloping up at full speed his
horse soaked in sweat he was pagas a
trusted member of Cyrus's personal staff
with the utmost urgency he shouted in
Greek and Persian king arur xerx is
advancing with a large army get ready
for
battle wild confusion followed as we
expected to be attacked any instant
before we could even form our battle
lines Cyrus immediately sprang from his
carriage and dawned his armor he leapt
onto his horse grabbed his javelins and
gave the order to arm and form ranks his
orders were quickly followed and the
Army rapidly moved into formation we
were arranged thus our commander clarus
was positioned on the right wing next to
the Euphrates beside CL marus were a
force of a thousand paphlagonian Cavalry
standing with them with the Greek
peltasts the light armed missile troops
Cyrus's second in command Aras formed up
in the center of the army with a large
host of Asiatic troops Cyrus was also
there with his 600 strong bodyguard of
elite Cavalry the horses in his Cavalry
Unit were equipped with headpieces and
chest guards the Troopers carried short
Greek style swords and all of them wore
breast plates and helmets except for
Cyrus who decided to go to battle with
his head and face
exposed but by noon there was still no
sign of the enemy and still we stood
holding our positions in the midday
glare then in the afternoon a white
cloud appeared on the horizon like a
disturbance of dust we watched as it
became a dark undulating shroud that
Rose upward and outwards to spread far
and wide along the plane like an
oncoming
storm then we could see here and there
the glint of bronze armor or polished
spear
points finally the ranks of the
approaching Army could be fully
[Music]
distinguished the antira mechanism is a
mysterious ancient Greek machine from
around 200 100 BC said by some to be the
world's oldest analog computer of course
you couldn't access the internet on it
not even dial up so the Greeks would
have missed out on trying Opera our
sponsor today the faster safer and
smarter Choice than any of the default
browsers out there Opera has a great
intuitive design with things like ARA a
state-of-the-art generative AI created
in collaboration with open AI it's
easily accessible and offers options to
explain explore and translate any
highlighted text on a page it also has
an integrated messaging system for
WhatsApp Facebook messenger and more a
free inbuilt VPN and ad blocker and most
importantly for me great little tab
islands for when I've gone on a
historical Source chasing Quest and I
want to have lots of online books or
documents open at once it's an effective
and secure browsing option that our
comedies would have loved so click on
the link in the description below to try
Opera out for free you won't be
disappointed thanks to oppra for
supporting history content on YouTube
[Music]
on the left facing us were the Persian
troops wearing white breastplates made
from reinforced linen they were
commanded by Tisa fernes the satrap of
carrier beside them was a unit carrying
wicker Shields and further along a group
of heavy armed infantry equipped with a
long wooden Shields reaching their feet
we were informed that these soldiers
were Egyptians further along along the
enemy line Cavalry and other Bowman were
arranged in divisions according to their
Nations each Marching In densely crowded
blocks and AR raay all along the front
of the Persian battle line with the
famous sied
chariots each Chariot had a spinning
slanted s fitted to the axle of their
wheels while other blades protruded from
the base and sides of the vehicles these
chariots could slice through whatever
opponents they encountered they were
placed one widely apart and poised to
dash at full speed into our ranks they
would cut down every man they
met during the Council of War Cyrus had
cautioned us to disregard the shouting
and clamor of the approaching Asiatic
troops but this warning was not required
the enemy approached us in deep silence
they slowly and rhythmically treaded the
ground in a steady March a moment later
Cyrus accompanied by his interpreter and
three or four of the companions rode up
to our stationary Force Cyrus called out
new orders to clarus instructing us to
advance immediately against the center
of the enemy battle line he believed AR
Xerxes could be found in this place he
said if we strike now at this Center
Point the battle is finished and
won clarus could clearly see the dense
formation of troops at the center of the
enemy battle line located to the left of
the Greek forces from Cyrus he knew that
the king AR Xerxes could be located in
this position but he also realized that
the great king had a greater numerical
superiority if the Greeks attacked in
that direction then ARA Xerxes could
hold the center and extend his line to
overlap and encircle Cyrus's Army on its
exposed right wing clarus was therefore
aware he could be outmaneuvered and
attacked on both flanks so he halted and
did not lead us away from the river
clarus sent back assurances that he
would see it all went well meanwhile the
Persian army was still advancing and we
was still halted the various contingents
of our Force began to shift formation
Cyrus rode forward from his battle line
and glancing in both directions he
surveyed the position of his army and
the oncoming Army of the enemy I saw
Cyrus and rode up from the Greek
formations to ask him if he had any
final orders to give us he came up to me
and asked me to spread words amongst the
Greeks concerning the final animal
sacrifice the sacred Omens had been
good while Cyrus was still speaking to
me we heard an urgent murmur passing
through the Greek ranks he asked me what
it meant I replied that it was a
watchword being passed through the
formations for the second time Cyrus
questioned who had been given the order
and asked what the current watchword was
to distinguish friend from foe I
responded Zeus Our Savior and Victor
Cyrus replied I accept that watch word
so be it eventually the two armies with
three or four furong apart less than
half a mile our Greek soldiers began
chanting the peon the hmn to Apollo then
we Advanced but as we moved forward part
of our battle line began to curve
inwards as the advance was uneven the
soldiers left behind quickened their
Pace into a run as a WAV like sinuous
Ripple spread across the Greek battle
line a thrilling cry burst from the
throats of the onrushing soldiers they
shouted in honor to the war god Elo Elo
part of our formation also clashed their
Shields and Spears to terrify the
Persian horses and before we had got
within arrow shot the Persians had
turned from their advance and fled from
us we pursued them with all the might in
effort we could manage and as we ran we
checked and cautioned each other with
shouts do not race keep in ranks the
Persian charioteers leapt from their
sced chariots so these vehicles now
careered and swerved through the fleeing
enemy host some of these uncontrolled
chariots rushed towards our oncoming
soldiers but our men saw them coming and
opened up gaps in our battle lines to
let them pass even when one of our
soldiers stood dumbfounded at the sight
like a confused horse on a race course
even he was only clipped on the heels by
the vehicle and suffered no lasting
injury
in fact except for someone on the Left
Flank who was wounded by an arrow we
Greeks did not suffer a single casualty
in this
encounter as you know it is not numbers
of men or their strength that bring
victories in war the finest victories
are achieved when the gods Grant greater
confidence and spirit to one force
against their enemies but I've noticed
something else in my time as a soldier
men whose Soul a is only to stay alive
in battle usually suffer a wretched and
dishonorable death but those who realize
that all men are mortal and will die
they will strive to gain honor and
somehow it is these men who more often
reach old age and have a happier
existence while doing
so Cyrus could see us routing and
pushing the enemy on his right flank he
was overjoyed and those about him gave
salutations as though he had already
been crowned as king but Cyrus did not
join our Greek Pursuit instead he kept
his Squadron of 600 Horsemen ready in
close order then he waited and watched
to see what king AR Xerxes would do next
Cyrus knew that the King still remained
at the center of the Persian army as it
was customary for Asiatic monarchs to
occupy that position the center is the
safest place in battle for a commander
since there are troops on either side on
both Flags anank s also if Riders are
needed to dispatch orders along the
lines the troops will receive the
messages in half the time King araz
Xerxes was indeed at the center of his
army but as the opposing Army was much
larger his Center position was behind
the left wing of Cyrus's battle line
when no enemy approached the front of
his own battle line Cyrus wielded his
army around as though to attack from the
closest flank but he now became
concerned that AR Xerxes might advance
in into the Gap created by the still
advancing Greek
formations if arz Xerxes did so then the
enemy Cavalry could close in on the
exposed rear of the Greeks and cut them
to Pieces Cyrus therefore charged to
meet the enemy head on with his 600
Elite Cavalry he rode against the 6,000
Persian Horsemen positioned in front of
the king he drove the king's Cavalry
into Retreat and it is said that he
personally slew their General at a
gases but almost as soon as the route
began Cyrus's own 600 Cavalry scattered
during the confused excitement of the
pursuit only a small group remained with
Cyrus and these men were his close
personal
companions suddenly Cyrus caught sight
of AR Xerxes unable to restrain himself
he cried out I see the man he charged
and delivered a mighty blow into his
brother's chest wounding the king
through his breastplate this is
confirmed by the Greek surgeon tus who
in Persian employment he later treated
the wound but as Cyrus delivered his
blow one of the Persians struck him
beneath the eye with a javelin causing
severe injury a struggle then ensued
between the king and Cyrus and their
companions fored to protect their
masters tius was close to the king and
gave a statement confirming that 27
Royal companions were slain during Close
Quarter
fighting
suddenly Cyrus was dislodged from his
horse and fell to the ground accounts
claim that when arates his most trusted
standard Bearer saw Cyrus on the ground
he leapt from his horse he threw his
arms around his Fallen Master to Shield
him from further blows immediately eight
of Cyrus's bravest companions dismounted
also to cover and protect him but
according to the same accounts King araz
Xerxes then ordered arpes to be attacked
and killed on the Fallen body of
Cyrus and so died Cyrus he was killed
fighting and every one of his faithful
bodyguard of friends and Court
companions died alongside him some say
that the Persians took the hand and head
from his body but I say he was a man of
Royal character the worthiest to rule
all the Persians he was the greatest
Persian since the Elder Cyrus the
founder of the their
empire as soon as Aras realized that
Cyrus had fallen in battle he turned and
fled the entire mass of Asiatic troops
under his command left the battlefield
with him King arter Xerxes and his army
pursued them until they rushed into the
baggage Camp of Cyrus the troops led by
Aras did not stand their ground and
immediately ran back through the camp
they headed towards the halting place
that they had occupied the night before
about 12 mil from the battle site as
soon as they entered the camp of Cyrus
King arter Xerxes and his followers
stopped the pursuit they scattered
various objects to loot and plunder as
Spoils of War a large part of the
Persian army became occupied in
pillaging the camp of Cyrus as though
they'd already obtained a universal
Victory by this stage our main Greek
force was only about 3 Mi away from
ater's position we were still pursuing
our original opponents as though the
army of ateres had been vanquished on
all
fronts King arter Xerxes was seen
advancing again but this time he was
approaching the rear of the Greek army
we turned around and prepared to receive
this enemy attack then and there but
instead of advancing directly towards us
the king's forces swerv to one side and
followed the route they had taken
earlier beyond the left wing of our
forces this would allow the king to
reunite with the various Persian units
who had fled from our Advance this
combined Persian Force Advanced to the
left of the Greek army as they drew
parallel they suddenly provoked great
fear in our ranks in that moment it
seemed as though the Persians might
flank us on both sides they would
encircle and Slaughter us the Greek
commanders therefore decided to extend
our battle line so that the river was
behind us but before that order could be
given the forces of the king passed our
position the Persians repositioned their
battle line in the exact place on
quarter where they'd begun their earlier
engagement and so we observed the enemy
forming up once more in full battle
order close to our ranks once again we
raised the pan and renewed the attack
with even greater enthusiasm once again
The Barbarians did not hold their ground
but turned and fled even further than
they had done previously we continued
our Pursuit until we reached a certain
Village
it was now impossible for us to know
what was occurring on The Wider
Battlefield or discover the intentions
of the enemy but we did observe an
emblem on the summit of the Hill it was
a kind of golden eagle with wings
extended perched on a high wooden bar on
top of a spear it was the Persian Royal
Standard as soon as we moved forward
again the enemy Cavalry deserted the
hill but they did not depart in battle
formation instead they streamed off from
all sides in different directions until
the crest was empty of
occupants then the Persians were simply
gone clarus did not immediately Ascend
the hill with his soldiers he halted us
at the base of the mound and sent lysius
of Syracuse uphill to inspect the
terrain and Survey the land Beyond
lysius galloped up to the summit and
returned to report most of the Persian
army was in full flight night at almost
the same time the sun was sinking
Beneath The Horizon so we Greeks halted
in this place but we wondered why Cyrus
was nowhere to be seen and why he had
sent no further messages to
us at that time we were still completely
unaware that he had died in battle in
our ignorance we assumed that Cyrus must
have disappeared in pursuit of the royal
army or Advanced to occupy some
strategic position further
ahead finally we decided to return to
our camp and we reached our tents by
late evening that is how the day of the
battle concluded when we entered our
quarters we found that most of our
property had been pillaged including
anything that could be eaten or drunk
the Persians had also ransacked the 400
wagons which Cyrus had prepared in case
our Expedition had need of further
supplies these wagons had been Laden
with great Quant quantities of grain and
wine we'd missed our meal that morning
since the Royal Army had appeared before
we'd made our usual Halt and
consequently when our food supplies now
ransacked most of us went hungry that
night
[Music]
too the Greek generals met again just
before Daybreak we were still surprised
that Cyrus had not reappeared or sent
someone to issue us with new orders
therefore we decided to collect our
weapons gather information and advance
to reconnect with Cyrus we're about to
start our March just as the sun was
Rising when a rider approached it was
proc descendant of damarus the laconian
they told us that Cyrus was dead they
said that Aras had retreated with the
remaining forces and was now at the
halting place they had departed from
from on the previous day Aras said that
they would wait one day for the Greek
army if we were coming then he would
begin the long journey back to Ionia
when our generals heard this news they
were distressed and great concern spread
through the Army clarus spoke as follows
oh if only Cyrus was still alive but
since he is dead tell Aras that the
great king is vanquished as you yourself
now observe no one stands against us if
you had not arrived we would have
resumed our March against AR Xerxes if
Aras joins us here then we pledge to
place him on the throne of Persia for
surely those who conquer should obtain
the
Empire those words he sent back with the
messengers meanwhile our soldiers
salvaged whatever food they could
acquire and butchered some of the
baggage animals which included oxen and
asses there was plentiful firewood as
there were abundant arrows near the
battlefield the routed Persians had
discarded them when pursuing there also
wicker Shields and the huge wooden
Shields the Egyptian soldiers had
carried we loaded these items onto the
empty wagons and this equipment provided
fuel to cook our meat and serve our
food it was early afternoon when Heralds
from King AR Xerxes and Tisa feres
arrived at our
camp they were all Persians except for
felinus a highly esteemed Greek who
resided at their Court felinus was
respected as a strategist with knowledge
of tactics involving heavy infantry
Heralds summoned our Greek generals and
delivered the following message the
great king AR Xerxes has won a victory
and slain Cyrus he bids the Greek to
surrender their weapons and present
themselves at the gates of his Royal
Palace then they may obtain whatever
terms are given we were despondent but
clarus replied with a few brief
words conquerors do not surrender their
weapons he turned to his officers and
said I leave it to you my fellow
generals to debate the issue and decide
the most honorable answer then clarus
left he went to conduct an animal
sacrifice and interpret the Omens as
revealed by the entrails felinus said to
the remaining Greek officers king art
Xerxes has you in his power you are in
the heart of his kingdom hemmed in by
impossible Rivers at any moment he can
send a vast multitude against you with
numbers so great that you could never
slay them all I recall theopompus an
Athenian officer replied all we have now
are our weapons and our Valor and one
cannot be used without the other if we
surrender our weapons then we will lose
our lives these are the only things of
value we possess felinus responded you
will regret that answer but the king
tells you this while you remain here
there is a truce but one step forward or
one step back and the truce ends there
will be
war after felinus had departed
Messengers finally arrived from Aras he
told us many of the Persian Nobles will
never accept me as a replacement King if
you are returning with our forces you
must reach us by tonight we set out on
the Homeward Journey a Daybreak
the sun was already sinking when clarus
summoned the Greek generals and officers
to a meeting he announced the
sacrificial Omens are favorable for us
to join the former allies of Cyrus we
must quickly organize our supplies then
eat gather our kit and form up to March
out on the
signal we will sound a horn then
leave we were more than a thousand miles
from Greece without any friendly guide
to show the way where would we obtain
Provisions we were in the heartland of
the enemy King surrounded on every Side
by many hostile cities and Nations
impassible Rivers hemmed Us in and
blocked the rout
[Music]
home